can i  just put another thing to you it's i've  watched this whole debate rage and  you've been completely  unflagging in your refusal to accept  defeat you know why though you know why  because if our country doesn't have fair  and free elections and if our country  doesn't have borders we don't have a  country okay we have crooked corrupt  elections here's what i was saying and  i've proven it is what i would say to  you i believe it was a free and fair  election and that you lost you don't  really believe that's my belief well  then you're a fool however then you're a  fan maybe i am a fool i'd be on the fool  in this conversation and you're a fool  and you haven't studied